good evening everyone
I want to welcome all of you to the
concluding event of our open house for
admitted students and thank our visitors
for taking the time to come to Yale to
look us over it was our pleasure to meet
with you and I know that our faculty and
students join me excuse me in hoping
that you like what you have seen we can
graduate you and are confident in the
next few days you will make the right
decision about your future education and
I suppose you will say and we'll make
them anticipate you'll say and we'll
make the right decision about your
financial aid but we will talk about
that later
Yale celebration of talent in all its
diversity is a continuing and ongoing
tradition it takes many forms the
University Commission's important
buildings that both compliment and
contrast with what went before our
school consistently brings leading
architects to lecture and teach who may
disagree among each other about how to
proceed in architecture yet share the
passion for architecture as an art but
first and foremost our job at the School
of Architecture is to nurture talent and
to enable intelligence consequently we
seek out the most talented students who
show the greatest potential for the kind
of independent thinking necessary for
professional leadership last Thursday
from this podium can we have the slides
please
last Thursday from this podium I shared
some thoughts and memories of Zhou Hadid
Norman our foster visiting professor my
friend and our colleague who died
unexpectedly seven days ago we were all
shocked
we remain so
our school enjoyed a rail relationship
and spirited collaboration with
Professor deed including this spring
term over many years she led advanced
studios in our school in 2006 she
received an honorary degree from the
University since her death many have
remembered professor Hadid as a creative
and path-breaking visionary a role model
for women in the profession and an
uncompromising artist possessing a
razor-sharp intellect she is very much
missed when Zhou came down with the
bronchitis that ultimately felled her
Patrik Schumacher Hadrian's design
partner who is also teaching with the
studio agreed to step in and deliver a
talk for this evening but with the sad
turn of events
patrick has to be in London this week
seeing - the memorial for professor
Saudi and innumerable other tasks as you
can well imagine to honor our beloved
colleague I am very grateful to Frank
Gehry Eero Saarinen visiting professor
of - Peter Eisenman Charles Gwathmey
professor and practice and - Dean
designate Deborah Burke three senior
distinguished members of our faculty
each of whom enjoyed strong personal and
long-lived histories with Zhou I want to
thank them for agreeing a relatively
short notice to undertake this
conversation in this evening so without
further ado I would like to turn the
evening over to Professor mark gage who
will serve as interlocutor - this
evenings conversation in honor of our
friend and our colleague Zhou Adi
mark Gage and the yes please
thank you Bob this is of course a
impossible task to try to fill in the
gap left by Zaha not only in
architecture but today I wanted to just
tell one kind of funny anecdote about
the last time she gave a lecture here
usually I've been teaching here for
about 16 years and when people give
lectures they usually save their
flagship projects to the very end so you
can usually count on something really
big showing up around the 50 minute in a
lecture and Zaha in a typical fashion
showing 400 slides and rapid-fire
succession had hit that level of
flagship project by like minute 8 and I
was sitting in the third row and cesar
pelli
and leon career was sitting in front of
me and i could swear simultaneously at
the same time they both turned at each
other and like Macaulay Culkin and home
alone were like they could not believe
how much work she had and how quickly
she was going through it and they
continued to talk about it later at the
reception so a lecture by Saha was a
real event it was a very fast-paced
event and it was really overwhelming the
amount of work and energy she put into
her workings on these tie three of us
about two and a half another above
introduced the three distinguished
senior faculty and I'm the guy with the
big wheel here but it's a real pleasure
and I'd like to thank you all I have a
couple of questions which I love trying
to hear this oh I know that I'm pretty
much going to you know throw a piece of
meat to the Lions and run away and learn
a mess
no gender appropriate to call it an
actor instead of an actress now then
we're all lioness we're all lioness who
are like that there you go
yes well I'm with you sister so it's
hard to imagine an architectural world
without zaha hadid in it certainly you
guys have been in the game much longer
than I had have and I wanted to start by
asking a frank first because we had
talked about this very briefly on the
phone the other day but when Zaha came
on your radar and so we could get a
little bit of backstory on how she
entered the profession and then maybe we
can segue that to further conversation
about education and practice down the
road but well it's it's hard to do this
to talk about her I think all of us
loved her very much and she was a good
friend and one of the things we shared
was teaching at Yale I think that this
has been a home to characters like us to
meet and play with the students that
come here and I used to try to schedule
my teaching gigs here with her being
here as Greg Lynn did so we could spend
time together because it was a big deal
I was doing the Vitra Museum in Basel
and while I'm ranked Switzerland and the
owner had hired Grimshaw first and me
and bondo and then he was going to build
another warehouse and I convinced him to
hire seiza Alvaro and
and then they were doing a firehouse and
we all sort of had just heard about
Jacques winning the peak competition I
may have the dates and the times all
screwed up it might have been fifteen
years in between those events so forgive
me but this is our remember and Ralph
being a very open and generous guy and
very intellectually stimulated by the
likes of us guys us people was open to
at least talking to her about doing the
firehouse even though it was at that
point I don't think she'd built anything
except winning the competition and so a
lot of discussion about backing her up
with with the proper team to help her do
it due to the building and it seemed
alright everything was going good she
made models and you've all seen the
building it's a pretty for a first
building is a pretty thrilling piece of
work and Christine fireEye's from Berlin
was also conspiring with me to help her
and I got a call about three four months
into it from the client saying oh my god
it's not working so guess what
Zaha couldn't be corralled by anybody
yes the poor local architect even at
that stage and so we all had to jump in
and
I get her on the right track but she
built it and built it well there was a
little bit of a SAG and one of the beams
wasn't her fault
a Swiss engineer made a mistake it's
never the architects ville no no no and
then the damn firemen didn't want to
move into it and it really worked
I mean it really worked as a firehouse I
swear I guarantee you were they didn't
want to move into it and I think really
well fun views it as an exhibit Center
ah but that got her started she got a
parking garage or something next to it
or down the street he in the same town
then she got the ski lift Cincinnati and
she took off like a rocket
ah how does she do it how'd she do it
Peter I mean she went from that to about
four hundred people working and all over
the world and pretty much good stuff
some of it really great and great
architect I think so Deborah you went to
AAA at the same time it's all was there
that's right we were in last night's in
Bremen Ilias unit and to whoever said
earlier today Ilias there all the time
that was true then too
I was a visitor for one year at the AAA
and saw how obviously got her
architectural education there and she
was I Frank and I were talking about
this earlier today she wasn't wearing
Prada and it's a Miyake then she kind of
made her own clothes but she was as
dramatic sort of spectacularly dramatic
in her
presence at the school then as a student
as she became in the profession itself
she had that confidence then uh I don't
didn't know her well enough to know
whether she had the confidence or she
was capable then of pretending to have
the confidence vision architecture I
think can be the same thing she
certainly had the talent she had the
talent for sure uh but you know later on
in her career that that way of
presenting herself people started
calling her diva this and diva that
Nolan craft but that wasn't her I mean
that was her the way she dressed and
things but happy warmer yeah I think
people realized she was missing well she
could be brusque wait I mean I mean
let's know oh here we go Peter well I
mean not to me but I loved you Peter
yeah there were there were there were
times when her public behavior was you
could say problematic I mean when you
weren't with her you could be far away
again er we're talking about her you
know welcome in you know really confused
we know I think what we really ought to
do is is realize that this was an
extraordinary person number one I and I
think that to me is more than anything I
remember about Saha when one would ever
come to London no matter how big or how
small etc she was always going out of
her way for one number one and she
always called things like it was even
with her success she was able to look at
her colleagues and to the other
Archy stars let's say around and say
things that are really needed to be said
I think she never held back I think she
was a terrific critic as you know as as
well and I thought she had an enormous
integrity about even her former closest
friends and her commentaries on people
were very accurate and so as a person I
think what what was part of her success
was the magnet magnetic condition of her
personality she was she may not have
been a diva but she was she was electric
right and when she walked into the room
you know she walked into the room okay
with no question about it
she was never backstage and I thought
that was wonderful in her and how much
she had suffered
I mean don't forget for the longest
period of time and I'm not sure the
difference between when I met her in 74
when she was around the Institute in New
York when REM was there I don't know
what year five or six okay
but there's a long time from the peak
competition let's say to the firehouse
to Cincinnati I mean Cincinnati was the
idiot what was 20 years from the peak to
Cincinnati Cincinnati so I mean let's
face it
there was a tough struggle for her
remaining who she was in the environment
that she was in and and don't forget the
she was in a colonial environment and
she chose to stay in London and I think
there was an enormous energy that
propelled her keeping loving for those
20 years because some people could have
given up and I think Cincinnati was one
of her triumphs and you know and and
that opened the floodgates that say and
I think she never looked back but she
never forgot who she was how she had to
struggle how other people had to
struggle and you know I thought she was
an enormous Lea a person of enormous
integrity and who her friends were
uh-huh
and she knew who her friends were over
the years that's it yes right
she never deserted those people ever so
that's not a diva right no well I
remember seeing this photograph from
Philip Johnson's 90th birthday I think
what year was that look to Bob to
history for in 1906 so much 1996
like the personnel Rainman of
architectural but in that picture it's
kind of striking because really there's
like 20 guys there's Frank and Peter and
Jack Robertson David childs and Stanley
Tiger men and I'm leaving out like Bob
where were we I think was that the
fourth season or C yeah but it's
literally like 20 of the most famous
male white architecture architects you
could recognize and then Zaha they're
wrapped in a white cape and I remember
seeing that and thinking like how did
she break into that that's like not just
the upper echelon architecture that's
like the whatever the hallowed circle of
New York architecture nonetheless in her
being from London to kind of follow up
on Frank's question of course she was
like immensely talented and overcame
quite a few obstacles not only being
Arab being a woman at that time period
but how did she get from that position
as a star student at the AAA winning a
competition that wasn't ultimately built
to that stratosphere in less than really
about 15 years 10 or 15 years what do
you think it is that allowed her to be a
comment Joseph Jimin Benigni wrote a
piece where he a eulogy where he starts
out by saying Zaha was a comment what do
you think propelled that comment I would
take a guess a commitment to her work
she you know she really believed in what
she was doing it was you make original
it always had enormous energy but I
would argue commitment and if she had
integrity about people I think she had
commitment to the work and I think it's
a great lesson for future architects who
were here I'm
talking about that I mean I think it's
really important to place her not in the
professional but how what she would mean
to somebody that's going to start
architecture and 80 percent 90 percent
of this audience are future architects
and to me that commitment to being good
you know in our own idea of what good
was and she wasn't going to tolerate
mediocrity that's what I mean she was
brusque when there were things that were
mediocre about whatever she was in
Cynthia would tell you a story about
when we were at a any conference in
Ankara and she reminded me today that we
were being housed somewhere Cynthia can
tell the story better but she refused it
was student house I don't know if
student housing she said this is no good
for anybody we're not going to and
everybody said yeah this is no good and
Cynthia had to go and and and quickly
find you know hotels that would take
these people I mean that's the kind of
thing she wouldn't accept mediocrity
yeah but she made a commitment to
learning how to build those things yep
yeah so but that was no easy right easy
thing she found the programs and the
people at new hutter yeah deliver and
she found that in Patrick there's a a
partner Patrick Schumacher so we keep
mentioning the I know the peak was a
obviously an incredibly pivotal moment
in her career and I guess the question
is maybe per Deborah taking over the
school and thinking about the next
generation of architects I was thinking
about that the peak competition and
there's some interesting I don't know
there apocryphal stories but I think it
was her scheme had already been rejected
and herati Sasaki rescued it from the
pile and the client came and said he
wanted a building that looked like his
new Lamborghini did you tell me this or
no it looked like a new Lamborghini so
they pulled it around I physically
pulled it out of the pile and the rest
is history but I was thinking about this
because the Guggenheim Helsinki
competition in which everybody every
architect the world was trying to
recreate Frank's success in Bilbao
received 1715 entries so for this kind
of young generation just the feel of
sylheti with the computer the ease of
access of information it's almost as if
the competition as a vehicle has been
taken off the table
like if Zaha was graduating from school
now with her talent and drive
how would she make her career in the
absence of that avenue of a competition
do you enter competition still I feel
but I don't think the competition is as
limited in its opportunities as you
presented by the Guggenheim example I
think there's still many opportunities
and competitions and the invited
competition I thought you and getting
invited but and and I think Frank's role
in Vitra is a key part of that story as
well that the way you move forward is to
get support yeah I got that happen to me
and and so the competition is a small
part of that and the support of your
colleagues your teachers the people
you've worked with when you're really
good and when you work really hard yeah
that's how it begins to unfold
so my first work came recommendations
from other people in the design field oh
yes architecture
mark ID one of the things that
characterizes her as really unique has
to do with the term I spoke on here last
fall that is Authority and what's
interesting about Zaha as opposed to
other people know and I think it
characterizes something very unique
about her as teachers you can teach
liqueur BCA you can even teach me
slander oh you can teach Aldo Rossi I
mean there any number of acolytes who do
Aldo Rossi in Italy today probably
better than Rossi the one thing you
could never do was teach Saha because it
was so unique to her being and her
artistic sensibility that even though
she was an authority it was an authority
that could not be taught and I think
that that tells you something very
unique about her being I mean a lot of
people can do Frank right a lot of
people can do easy
hey I like the markings of a try and
imitate Frank come on that's annoying is
not succeeding
I didn't they lose him as a model
all right you couldn't yeah you're do
you strike as a model I just mean that
as a compliment come on I will say they
don't they don't use AHA it's harder
it's not my personal signature yeah
much harder right so that ring
whatever was mentioned in the other
that's something I had talked to a
number of students today about that kind
of curating and network of allies and
friends and mentors and clearly Zaha had
a guardian angel in in Frank with a
vitro project were there any key mentors
and your career moving forward were
there any really really important ones
that you would like to credit the names
would mean I don't know I think what
were the teachers or colleague
Fred Fred uh sure was a graphic designer
designer worked with themes for a long
time he I worked with him at the Gruen
office close friends he was called by
Danziger to do a studio and Danziger and
Fred got me to do it uh so that was the
first building that's always the hardest
one to get seems speaking from
experience
and a lot of that came from people I
work with that grew and so that had
worked with me for about four or five
years and Philip Johnson he could go
both ways
the dynamite stick now the funny story
with Philip is by accident I made a lamp
that looked like a fish and it was it
was it was and Philip heard about it and
he and David Whitney his partner called
me to have dinner and they lectured me
on you mustn't do this Frank this is a
negative thing to do in the starting
career in architecture was and then a
week later
Aggie guns bought will ask me to make
one for her brother who was getting
engaged and there was an engagement
party in New York the fish lamp was
there and the next morning I got a call
from Jasper Johns Philip Johnson's know
buying them and Philip wanted one so now
when I was at my open house in the 90s
Philip Johnson was teaching here
teaching a studio in which Peter isin
there was as ta right that's right for
real
but I was you know a little nervous and
I went up to the sixth floor and was
running to get into the pit to see her
review and I ran smack into Philip
Johnson like like chest to chest and he
kind of like stood back and he goes well
but where are you from I said I said
well I'm from Nebraska sir
and he said Oh son you got it all wrong
this building says architecture on the
front not agriculture but Peter you also
I would imagine Philip Johnson was
something of a mentor to you but Colin
Rowe also who were your big mentors and
allies as you were founding a career I I
would say mentors not allies I mean I
think there's a big difference okay um
certainly Colin was an enormous
influence I mean and Tony can certainly
attest to that I think at a certain
moment
Manfredo tough really was a was an
enormous energy and influence and at the
at the end let's say Jacque Derrida was
you know we spent a lot of time and did
a project in a publication together
those will be the three main outside
influences let's say outside of Philip I
mean Philip there's no question that
Philip was really important to the
Institute and what we were doing there
and
he was I mean I can remember one of the
great gestures of folk which is what
ties you to these kinds of people we've
been working on house 10 and the client
wanted to build the thing in the fall
and I told him don't worry we'll get the
working drawings done during during the
summer and that summer I went with Bob
Stern and others to Europe and messed
around with the Biennale if you remember
right it was it was a marvelous time and
we we had a great time I came back from
Italy and the clients there's the hole
in the ground no drawings right and so
on the spot he fired me boom like that
and you know this house was something we
put a lot of time in and so I went to a
dinner that the new members dinner at
the Century Club and I was sitting next
to Philip and he said to me how's the
house going I which is what he would
always ask his you know friends and
young younger architects and I said it's
dead he said what do you mean I said I
said I got fired he said how much did
you lose I said ten ten thousand and
without saying anything the next day an
envelope came from Philips office and I
opened it and there was a note that said
this is a long term note loan don't
worry about it and there was $10,000
will you be my Philip I'm
I mean that's so you know it doesn't
happen very often but there it is so
many even call I mean as a patron yeah
and that was more of a she was a friend
no he looked after a lot of us huh
he looked after the a bunch of us yep a
knowledge you say you're a question and
it's a two-part answer
I'd say mentors and two of the three of
them are here and might be surprised to
hear this are actually Tony Peter and
Ken at the Institute where I showed up
as a very young woman having gone to art
school and it was like being immersed in
a full-body dye bath of architecture I
thought you're going to say to maleness
to a lot of wonderful women who work
there who went on to do great and
interesting and important things so
there was that that was immersion in
architecture in the Indigo bath of
architecture and and the other isn't
from architects at all to people and I'm
going to use this to come back to Zaha
one will Miller from the Commons
architecture foundation because I got a
job out there and that brought a level
of visibility to my work that hadn't
come previously and that was a wonderful
thing and the support of patrons of
architecture like that I think remains
critical and the other and the reason
this gets back to Zaha is it's because
it's about knowing what you believe
sticking with it and saying it sometimes
fiercely I interviewed for a job in
Louisville Kentucky many years ago I did
not get the job went to a small firm
from California two years later my phone
rang and voice on the phone said I want
to hire you to do a hotel for me you
won't remember me because I wasn't in
the room I was on the Polycom when you
interviewed for that job in Kentucky but
I liked everything you had to say I
wrote it down I have a project for you
now so
to the point being made about Zaha she
knew what she believed she wanted to go
and do that that's true for everybody
here to know you learn and then know
what you believe and hang on to it
fiercely because it will get you work I
know the a couple people have written
about that period in AHA's life between
winning the peak and going through all
sorts of trials and tribulations with
winning the Cardiff Bay competition
twice and it being taken from her to the
point where she finally essentially got
a Cincinnati bill which as I said was a
20-year period of struggle and I've
wondered if maybe Frank because you're
so celebrated and so many wonderful
things are written about have you have
you had periods like that in your
practice where you were actually
struggling and where you everything
wasn't firing on all cylinders where you
had to well get a loan from Phillip
Johnson we're getting things built were
there any down times I think so isn't it
is this conversation one of it
no I pretty much I I didn't take any
business practice courses or anything
but I had a sense from the beginning
that I I knew that borrowing money was a
bad thing to do I didn't have a lot of
money we were really not in poverty but
difficulty but when I started I I
wouldn't borrow money and I made another
rule that everybody that worked for me
would get paid so I wouldn't take any
freebie labor
and I also added to that that at the end
of the year they would get a bonus so
for five years I worked alone day and
night but stuck to your guns and I think
that works by the way I think I would
advise people to understand that now
there are ways to borrow money and if
it's family money and stuff like that
it doesn't get you in trouble maybe but
Peter did you ever pay the money back
you know yeah not in so many words no I
accepted the gift I I remember I think
it's important to put him into
perspective too because there were lean
years we went out to UCLA again Robert
was with us and for a thing called seven
days in May I believe what was called at
UCLA in 74 Oh what I this is and and we
were all of the Eastern architects the
Venturi's were there Scully was there
Colin Rowe everybody went white Gray's
you know whatever and we were invited by
the silvers okay and the silvers were
Caesar Pelli
know that's the story and Caesar and
Tony Lumsden and at et cetera I can't
remember that he knows all of the names
because and man we're going to all give
lectures at UCLA and the first day there
were lectures I was wearing a UCLA sure
I remember and he remembers that and so
everybody said there's a party at this
garage and we were all in big fancy
Cadillac cars when we drove up this
garage
right there and I asked one of the guys
from the server said whose garage is
this I mean or whose it's a big place
right and there were a hundred people
there and you know it's a very festive
party and I
they said it's that guy over there right
and I said who's he and he said yeah he
is Frank Gehry and I and I said why is
he given the party he's an architect but
he wasn't good enough to be in the
silvers right that was a full story yes
it was yeah that was my first
introduction to it right so he also went
through periods of time of weather world
was problematic well there was a
backstory I'm not going to mention names
but go ahead glad I wasn't invited but
two people at work for me were put on
the silvers and they were using my
buildings and I remember sitting with
headache and and the person was
lecturing he was showing the Concord
Pavilion and so on with them he said you
did that right I said yeah he said why
is he I said because he's a silver at
the time I was doing developer work and
wasn't considered you know intellectual
enough for for the group for something I
would so I went to Uli urban land it's
two in Texas for a conference with
shopping center developers and stuff and
a gentleman that I will remain nameless
was part of that event and spoke about
other about architecture and spoke about
the New York architect community and he
sort of depper Kotori about he didn't
mention names but he just said you know
not for developers that's this is a
different culture
there's rather negative about them lyric
5 yeah and so then I came back to LA and
I was supposed to go to Harvard to the
urban design conference which I used to
go to regularly because I spent some
time at Harvard you don't my loves
mission just a little bit of time I love
I've been here longer anyway
I was going to leave that afternoon on a
Monday afternoon I had the tickets and
everything I was going to leave for
Boston and something curious I went to
UCLA to the silvers conference and that
person who spoke at the UL I got up and
turns out he was a great friend of the
whites the silvers and the greys and
everybody and he spoke just the opposite
you saying just the opposite in that in
this conference and I thought what the
hell's going on here and then Peter gets
up and starts whoo I was terrified of
because there was one of the guys in my
office Craig Hodges that knew you and he
would as a Yale graduate yeah he was
always telling me to look Peters this
genius and he
he made him you know appear don't go
near he's scary
so the curiosity I went and there's
Peter I follows this gentleman who is
now saying nice things about him
who said bad things about him before
he's got his sweater on and he's to say
better I'm sure same sweater
I said you saying talking about is this
his process and he's describing the
euphoria he has was drawing and how it
takes him into another Zen move moved
into outer space and he's describing
this and so it sounded like all my
artist friends who got stoned all the
time it sounded familiar and I kind of
liked what he was showing how six or
four or something which I didn't
understand that the stairway to nowhere
and the master bedroom bed had a slice
through it so that part I understand my
parents who definitely understand anyway
it was it sounded good so I then
cancelled Boston and had a party at my
loft my office my garage but I invited
all my artist friends for protection so
I had everybody enjoy that all became
famous later but they were all there and
supported me and protected me from these
bad people
anyway we became friends I got hustled
big time and I ended up putting five
grand into the Institute with a lip
stand and started going to meetings and
fell in love with this lovable creature
what's interesting because we have for
the admitted students the the New York
five was the group of lights which were
poor
proto Noonie of Nouveau modernism you
know mod real - it's a Bob Stern was one
of the graves which was first modernist
assorted this and I think the silvers
described as more technologically
interested in West Coast group I guess
that it's interesting because we have
some well you didn't quite make it but
you're not are a silver now I'm sure
they didn't make you how important was
it having a group like that like
practicing with a group or at least
having an affiliation with a group of
other architects that supported a
similar idea on port would it was it
having a kind of cabal moving forward in
your early career oh I I mean first of
all if you're competitive which a lot of
architects are I am very competitive
I mean today is like Nirvana for me
being competitive against Harvard you
know one of the great great excitements
right I mean you know this a day you
want to win okay that's true I mean I
you got to have competitive juices lower
today or you know we're right and if
you're competitive you got to have a
team and there is a Robert and I know
less competitive we had two teams and
sometimes we'll play against one another
sometimes we play together and it was
really in those days very important and
uh has to have meetings we thought
conferences I mean what would you know
invent things to do because none of us
had very many other things to do and it
was in those days the world we survived
and I think to all of the people that
were involved they were we look back I
mean Robert and I would look back and I
think Frank would too to say you know
would that would we had some teams today
of young people would there were those
kinds of struggles because we were
thought we were struggling over
something pretty important I mean it
looks back and you say not so but we
thought it was important at those days
and because we did believe in what we
were doing and we did have a commitment
and there were love energy poured into
those kinds of things and you know would
one like to see that today you betcha
you don't like there's teams today you
you seem to think as a team that the
triple O's but I'm I ain't convinced I
mean that I don't see him play much I
threw it out for Frank this is Oscar rod
said the only thing worse than being
talked about it's not being talked about
so at least we made the cut yeah in mind
but that's the subject for another
symposium I wanted to um well Frank you
had a kind of group but I know you were
really heavily influenced by the art
community and you had a lot of artist
friends it seems like and when these
guys were mostly hanging out with
architects maybe talk about that early
interdisciplinary play between your
artist side and your architecture yeah
yep yeah so there was a small
architecture group in LA
that that existed and when I did the
Danziger studio there was a lot of
shooting at me because instead of having
the window flush with the exterior
plaster I recessed it and so I created a
sort of a fake pole shade that didn't
exist on the inside that was a terrible
danger
thing to have done for these people and
so they started yelling at me I didn't
care much about what they were talking
about I was really looking for a way of
working that was about building but
making things not necessarily going in
the shop and banging doing stuff but to
get closer to the construction because
some of my early days before
architecture I was a truck driver and I
used to install breakfast nooks and
things like that and I was always doing
things with my hands and during the
course of the building of the Danziger
studio several of the artists I would
find them on this construction site so I
became friends with them because they
were positively interested in what I was
doing I knew their work I knew them from
their work I'd followed their work
already I knew who they were and to get
invited into the club so where they were
working where I were they would come to
my place I was working and it was kind
of a very hands-on thing many of them
were building their own studios off and
on changing it a couple of them would
change
you know you'd go to dinner Saturday
night and you'd sit in one part of the
studio and it would be all set up like a
stage set and then two weeks later would
be another part again and different
paintings there and I like the dynamic
of it I like the immediacy of it the
directness of it I could understand it I
could get into it and I wanted to keep
doing that it was different than what
the architects were doing and they
engaged me a lot by the way just so we
don't leave anybody out
Deborah Burke was on a team - yeah and
spoken much about it what is next
she she what you were on a team no I'm
not going to say I wanted to get into
the conversation no I was gonna have her
over here she was out of town she was on
her TV yeah you mean the young
architects of the Institute no no I I
may be wrong
weren't you weren't you involved in a
magazine okay so yeah we're being kind
and gracious and I I appreciate that but
come on that was it - you left your team
behind no no no no at all but the team I
remember and being important and were
the people I hung out with in New York
when I moved back to New York after
college and they were artists and
writers and we occupied the city of the
night and I think my ongoing interest
with sort of invading old buildings and
transforming them has to do with that
urban existence early in my career I
don't think this is the team that Peter
is actually talking about but but these
were my teammates and and we haunted the
then dangerous streets of New York City
and invaded buildings in a variety of
ways that remains my muse she has the
team I'm talking about
Peter's trying to start something no I
ran over make sure everybody she also it
was part of the reason where the world
was are you're on a team now we now know
that a vitamin I thought you're on this
team I'm just kidding I mean this is
this a team is some is is sort of out an
outlier group right this isn't my art
group by Wednesday well I think I have a
final question and then we'll open it up
in audience a little bit but with
Frank's permission can I read that first
statement you made in the art forum sure
sure okay
so Frank wrote the piece regarding Zaha
in art form the first paragraph is I
think a good good place to at least
start a question that'll end it my
friends AHA died yesterday morning she
was a mere 65 years old when I saw her
last it was a couple of weeks ago at the
Yale University architecture school
where we were both teaching terms
studios this term something that we have
been doing regularly over the years we
do it not only because we like to teach
but also because we like being together
when we teach so over the years we have
managed to arrange our schedules to be
at Yale at that time so that we can meet
and greet and talk and drink and
complain and have fun and explore the
wonderful culture of Yale University I
guess my final question to each of you
is why do you teach and why Yale thanks
for teaching here talk first and you
Todd here and 80 started teaching here
in the early 78 78 yeah no I don't think
I mean I was taking when I would be a
visiting critic with Jim which yeah I
mean I would be on juries on Jim's
juries all the time but I was teach
doesn't matter I was teaching where
parallel with Jim yeah I I don't yeah
I can answer the question I'm here
because of Bob and we're all here I
think one of the things the one needs to
do is appropriately
give credit where credit has been due
for 18 years and I had the choice of
being at Princeton or here and I was
really ready to go to Princeton and Bob
said you got to come here and it was
really important for him to make that
gesture and it was important for me to
take it in the way it was made and for
me teaching is one of the three
important things in my professional life
that I do and it is very important to me
I never miss a beat with teaching a
building is important and in writing is
important and to me I get a lot of
energy from every time I teach because
you're in touch with brighter people
than you are faster people and if you
compare the debating about the young
faculty right now I'm talking about the
young spoons and they look younger and
faster and brighter every every every
year so I and one of the older guys the
the Silverbacks and all the new guys
right and that combination is is is very
important right and the having had
somebody watch over one which Robert
does right and to give us a flute of
young horses fabulous nothing better and
y'all has always been that kind of place
and I know that Debra in that tradition
it's always been as Robert it's a
standalone architecture school
it has always had an architect who
practices in an important way as a Dean
right and it's unique in the fundament
of architecture schools since the war
since the Second World War I can't speak
before because that's his purview but
that'll be next week's like next year
but is that going to divide the world I
don't think they are above I think that
to have here tonight the the grand
senior Bob Deborah fabulous you know for
them unbelievable and it could only
happen here yeah by total accident that
one of our great friends and colleagues
past and we were able to put this group
together terrific I teach cuz it feels
good that makes it selfish it does good
that makes it generous and it feels best
here that's it that was easy and I would
say I never talked as AHA about this but
I would recommend it
there's a freedom a willing to explore a
willing to put collisions together I I
was put on a jerk on a Leon creer jury
one
Leon who finally became friends with me
after he realized that I had read the
Camilo skip the book and I quoted from
it once and he all oh my god I was a
friendless but then he didn't like me
after I did the Eisenhower memorial so
I'm trying I'm in good shape but I think
there's that kind of open friendly kind
of controversy that goes on and and it's
probably I don't know any other place
where you can pull it off and it's been
conducted it he took it to a whole new
place that it hadn't been and I think I
think we learned a lot from that thank
you well thank you very much he will
open the floor to a couple questions we
have time and I believe there is a
microphone person there okay so you have
a question raise your hand they got to
be the questions it can't be all dead no
they will you just have to give them
time it's a question ever we need to get
the mic because there are people in
other rooms
thank you for the discussion Peter
mentioned the sort of replicability of
Ahaz Authority but I guess I just want
to ask how that might be compared to say
Frank Lloyd Wright who was some sort of
idiosyncratic and irascible Authority in
architecture who in many ways saw to it
that his authority was replicated and
whether that was something of AHA's
agenda to make her design aesthetic into
a style into a goal for designers well
when I started school in 50 I'm a little
beyond from being behind Frank Frank
started in 30 I think but when I started
imperfectly ever everybody had Frank
Lloyd Wright books on their desks they
had the nature of materials they had any
number of Frank Lloyd Wright books and
it was the authority in the school
because it was above our school and we
weren't doing bizarre but we were doing
the next best thing to it was Frank
Lloyd Wright and I can tell you from
personal experience a personal story in
52 we had Paul Rudolph as a critic and
Paul set a project
and I was in his studio and I did a
Frank Lloyd Wright project and they the
juries were closed in those days when
they opened the doors I went in and I
had gotten the highest mark in the class
of first mention from doing absolutely
practically tracing Frank Lloyd Wright
so the next project was a yacht club and
I had remembered from reading my books
that Frank Lloyd Wright had done a thing
called the Yahara Boat Club and so I
traced off the Yahara Boat Club and
turned it in and I was really excited
when I heard Paul Rudolph was coming
back to be on our jury in in 52 and I
thought hey another top-grade right and
so I raced in after the jury was over
and there was a big X which in those
days meant you had failed the six weeks
and it caused me to go to a summer
school to make up the six we couldn't do
it any other way and I went up to mr.
Rudolph and I said mr. Rudolph what
what's the story here the last time I
got a first mention and this time I got
a Chomp and he said it's okay to do it
once not twice and with a big lesson
another question
well then if not I think we'll thank
Mark for putting together a wonderful
set of questions and our great speakers
and guests and faculty from Gary Deborah
Burke
Peter Osmond for sharing their thoughts
about saw and about themselves
you